tous merci de nous retrouver en direct
sur figaro live nous avons choisi de
consacrer ce direct au sujet de la
vaccination des enfants face au co vide
19 à partir de ce mercredi 15 décembre
les enfants âgés de 5 à 11 ans
considérés comme à risque fragile c'est
à dire ceux souffrant de comorbidité où
vivent dans l'entourage d'une personne
fragile pourront se faire vacciner ce
sujet ce sujet suscite beaucoup
d'interrogations et parfois l'inquiétude
chez vous les internautes vincent
bordenave journaliste au service science
du figaro va nous aider à tout
comprendre et répondre à vos questions
bonjour vincent jours merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et d'être en
direct aujourd'hui avec nous qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire de la dynamique de la
pandémie à l'instant où l'on se parle
dans cette tranche d'âge des enfants de
5 à 11 ans alors ce que j'veux qu'on
remarque depuis plusieurs semaines c'est
que le virus circulent intensément chez
chez les plus jeunes ce qui est assez
logique parce que c'est la seule partie
de la population qui est pas qu'ils
aient pas vaccinés on a des taux un type
d'incident ce record qui datait de 2000
pour pour pour cent mille c'est à dire
quasiment 1%
et ce qui contribue à
lancer la dynamique de la pandémie au
niveau niveau national qui est qui dans
sa cinquième bague on le sait qui est
liée aux variantes d'attaqués
extrêmement extrêmement contagieux
combien d'enfants aujourd'hui sont
concernés par par par cette
vulnérabilité et donc du coup l'idée
qu'ils puissent être vaccinés à partir
de mercredi 15 plusieurs centaines de
milliers me semble j'ai pu les chiffres
précis en tête mais c'est un nombre
important mais l'enjeu de la vaccination
des enfants à risque il est vraiment
dans une optique de protection
individuelle on considère pas que les
vaccinés va freiner particulièrement
l'épidémie mais on sait que c'est un
certain nombre d'enfants il peut y avoir
un risque de complications on appelle ça
des pimms
c'est tout simplement un emballement du
système immunitaire des enfants qui vont
avoir besoin de d'assistance
respiratoire et donc ces enfants là qui
sont soit en surpoids soit qui souffre
déjà qu'ils ont déjà fait de grosses
crises d'asthme etc
nécessitent une protection
supplémentaire doudou l'enjeu de la
vaccination est ce que ça veut dire que
ces enfants fragiles en cours les mêmes
risques que les adultes c'est à dire un
risque de formes graves ou de décès
identique à ce que veut que subissent ou
dont sont victimes les adultes concernés
par le cos vide je crois marque depuis
le début de la pandémie c'est que les
enfants font moins de forme grave ça
c'est ça reste ça reste vrai quelles que
soient les variants quel que soit le
pays quelle que fût la vague on a
cependant remarqué particulièrement aux
états unis pendant l'été une
augmentation des formes graves chez chez
les plus jeunes
il ya plusieurs raisons qui expliquent
cet été la pandémie était drivé comme
comme aujourd'hui par le variant
d'attaqué qui extrêmement contagieux et
donc le virus a circulé de manière
beaucoup plus important dans les
établissements alors que pendant les
premières vagues rappelons-nous la
plupart du temps les dans la plupart des
pays des écoles étaient fermées c'est la
france ça fait quand même exception là
dessus donc les risques de contamination
était moins fort et donc par définition
les des enfants étaient un peu exclu de
de la pandémie maintenant ils sont ils
sont rentrés dans dans la vue dans la
vulnérabilité comme comme tout un chacun
et donc seat est assez logique on
remarque une augmentation des formes
graves et il ya un autre élément qui
rentre en compte et c'est pour ça qu'ont
choisi de vacciner le public un risque
parce que aux états unis il ya plus
d'enfants à risques liés à des contextes
d'obésité infantile beaucoup plus élevé
beaucoup plus élevé qu'en france et
c'est pour ça que le choix de la has et
du gouvernement depuis depuis autorité
de santé la haute autorité de santé
pardon de vacciner exclusivement les
enfants rient c'est un peu
quelque chose d'assez da c'est évident
il n'y a pas de y'a pas nécessairement
d'inquiétude encore par rapport au co
vite par rapport aux enfants mais on
sait que pour un certain nombre ça peut
être embêtant il ya quand même depuis
début de la pandémie j'ai regardé les
chiffres le week-end dernier donc
peut-être qu'ils sont plus à jour
aujourd'hui mais très enfants de moins
de 10 ans qui sont mort du co vide en
france en france depuis le début de la
pandémie la pandémie il y en a 3 il y en
a deux depuis le début la cinquième
bague donc c'est quand même d une
réalité on n'est pas sur un phénomène de
masse c'est pas nous c'est pas la grippe
de hong kong s'est pas vaincu dès 1956
ou où la grippe asiatique de 1957
à la fin des années 60 mais ceci dit il
existe ce risque pour un certain nombre
d'enfants et donc on fait le choix les
protéger individuellement en préparant
cette émission j'ai relevé quelques
commentaires d'internautes qui sont
nombreux justement sur ce sujet là sur
lefigaro.fr sous les papiers qui ont été
publiées sur le sujet de la vaccination
des enfants je vais vous citer deux
commentaires auxquels vous pouvez
peut-être répondre vincent le premier
qui vient d'un internaute qui n'a pas
souhaité révéler son identité quand l'on
sait que le vaccin n'empêche pas
d'attraper et contaminer les autres et
que les enfants dont aucun risque d'être
hospitalisé c'est quoi le but en les
vaccinant mégaphone 75 lui va dans le
même sens le vaccin ne protège pas de la
transmission donc pourquoi vouloir coûte
que coûte vacciner les enfants qui ont
très très très peu de chances d'être
hospitalisée pourquoi vacciner ou pas
ils transmettront de toute façon
qu'est-ce qu'on peut répondre dans les
internautes la question est légitime
elle se pose la première réponse c'est
que pour le moment on vaccine que les
enfants qui sont à risque de faire des
formes graves c'est une réalité ensuite
dans un deuxième temps la question de la
vaccination des enfants va se poser elle
se pose déjà un certain nombre de pays
ont fait choix de les vacciner ces cas
d'israël ces deux cas des états unis
c'est le cas aussi me semble à partir
d'aujourd'hui de de l'italie le canada
aussi j'ai du canada
la question est vraiment légitime partir
du moment où les vaccins sont très
efficaces contre les formes graves mais
que les enfants sont pas forcément un
risque quel est l'intérêt pour eux
l'intérêt il est d'un point de vue
épidémiologistes c'est que même si les
vaccins sont pas non pas une efficacité
à 100% ou à 90% sur les transmissions
ils ont quand même une efficacité qui
autour de 60 70 % en fonction des études
donc vacciner des enfants permettra
quand même de freiner il ya une publics
alliée une étude de l'inserm qui est
sorti vendredi dernier qui montre que en
vaccinant les enfants on les protège du
risque de fermeture des établissements
ce qui est quand même temps scolaire
établissements scolaires ce qui mine de
rien quelque chose d'important parce que
le principal danger pour les enfants
pendant qu vite c'est ça c'est la
fermeture des établissements et donc un
trou dans l'éducation et c'est quelque
chose de très grave et on a fait ce
choix là en mars 2020 on aimerait ne pas
avoir à le refaire mais toutes ces
questions se posent aujourd'hui et se
poseront plus demain parce que le
variant qui nous menacent le marion
actuelle c'est loin d'être tarie c'est
que les vaccins soient un peu efficace
le variant qui nous menace et qui est en
train de gagner du terrain ces cas au
royaume uni
marion mikron et variant omicron voilà
présente plus de résistance aux vaccins
et donc on s'interroge sur la capacité
des vaccins à freiner les transmissions
avec ceux avec ce variant et si ce
variant avec vraiment à déjouer notre
système immunitaire et à ne pas et à ne
pas freiner les que le vaccin est rendue
caduque sûre en tout cas le côté
transmission vacciner les enfants la
question se posera d'autant plus à ce
moment là il ya quand même beaucoup de
pédiatres qui qui s'interroge qui
demande à attendre les retours de ce qui
se passe aux etats unis on a quand même
la chance que certains pays aient
commencé avant nous et on va avoir des
données épidémiologiques et à dire on
sait quel est le nombre d'enfants à
l'instant où l'on se parle qui ont été
vaccinés vous parlez des états unis qui
va le signer en nombre les en voyant le
nombre de ces plusieurs millions
d'enfants qui ont déjà été vaccinées un
jeu le vent d'autan la voir mais je les
ai pas en tête donc je préfère pas dire
de bêtises il doit pas être compliqué à
retrouver je
vous parlais d'un élargissement de la
vaccination des enfants de 5 à 11 ans en
france à tous les enfants dans cette
tranche d'âge non plus simplement les
enfants fragiles ou à risque à telle
date pourrait se faire cette ouverture à
tous les enfants est ce qu'on a on a une
idée aujourd'hui si c'est dans quinze
jours si ça peut être alors si c'est un
choix qui est politique donc il va
dépendre du contexte sanitaire si la
cinquième vague arrive à arrive à son
pic dans l'est dans les prochains jours
on peut imaginer que cette cette
perspective soit se reporter si on
n'arrive pas à freiner la cinquième
vague on peut envisager au contraire de
l'accélérer ce qui est inévitable c'est
que dans cette une semaine il ya les
vacances elle vacances scolaires ce qui
va contribuer à freiner un peu la
dynamique épidémique il y aura les fêtes
de fin d'année qui pourront
réaccélérer tout ça sur les fêtes de
noël ou du nouvel an
donc la décision se fera pendant cette
période là si les vacances contribuent à
vraiment ralentir l'épidémie peut-être
qu'il faudra pas le peut-être que c'est
parce qu'il faudra peut-être que le
gouvernement ne jugera pas nécessaire de
le faire en janvier inversement si la
dynamique reprend avec ses menaces en
plus au micro on peut essayer de
rajouter une barrière supplémentaire
face à face à face au virus et donc ce
qui nous manque la dent dans l'arsenal
c'est vraiment vacciner ce foyer de
contamination qui est qui les enfants et
toutes les limites
on lit beaucoup qu'il ait encore des
doutes qui subsistent sur la vaccination
des enfants et qui font qu'aujourd'hui
on n'impose pas la vaccination dans
cette tranche d'âge
c'est quoi ces doutes qui subsistent sur
quoi ils reposent sur quels points
repose-t-il ses doutes
et qui fait que voilà l intérieur on
attendait un duel un vaccin c'est pas
quelque chose d'anodin qu'il arrive
c'est un acteur médical comme comme
n'importe quoi quand un acte médical
c'est pas quelque chose d'anodin
objectivement la question des intérêts
individuels elle se pose on peut il
répondre sur sur des éléments qui songe
que gisaient la fermeture des écoles
un livre dans un dans un cycle de deux
pandémies même pour même quand on n'est
pas à risque personnellement c'est ça
quelque chose qui a un coût un coût
sanitaire un coup et
psychologique donc il ya cet ensemble
d'éléments qu'il faut prendre en compte
mais elle le fait est que pour le moment
les enfants sont pas à risque de faire
des formes graves de la maladie et donc
la question légitime d'autant qu' on
pourrait même penser à condition que
cette circulation dans les écoles n'est
pas un impact très négatif sur sur
l'ensemble de la population qui serait
peut-être plus intéressant pour un
enfant de tomber malade et de faire son
système immunitaire par rapport à ce
virus pour que en grandissant le système
immunitaire et en mémoire ce virus dans
son ensemble et non pas et non pas un
petit bout comme comme c'est le cas avec
les vaccins et dans une optique
individuel sur le long terme et même
collectif sur le long terme la question
la question peut se poser alors on
parlait des pays qui ont commencé la
vaccination
pédiatriques les etats-unis israël et
canada vous parliez de l'italie et je
précise que l'italie le fera à compter
du 16 décembre c'est à dire ce jeudi
cette semaine pour l'ensemble des
enfants concernés
c'est à dire cinq ans onze ans que les
vaccins autorisés pour la vaccination
pédiatriques on en parle beaucoup de
moderna de pfizer en français de la
série fire qui est privilégiée d'une
part parce que si je suis content en
plus grand nombre et qui sur les études
pour le mans a montré vraiment très peu
d'effets secondaires il ya un léger
signal sur le vaccin moderna pour les
moins de 30 ans et donc comme c'est un
sujet quand même ô combien sensible le
choix est fait de deux mètres toutes les
billes et yahoo là où il ya le moins de
doute besoin d'aidé même s'ils sont
faits secondaires sont très faibles de
toute façon y compris pour le pour les
autres vaccins mais la partie au moment
où il peut y avoir un signal à sur un
vaccin ont choisi les quartiers parce
qu'on a on a le choix quand c'est comme
une force est-ce que la dose qu'on
injecte aux enfants est la même que
celle qu'on injecte hôtels et les
différentes il ya un dosage il ya un
noah spéciales et mêmes aux états unis
la new york
le pass and i ter étendue aux enfants
mais seulement à partir d'une seule dose
le royaume-uni a aussi fait le choix de
deux que de vacciner les enfants avec
une seule dose donc on voit que c'est
pas forcément le ça va pas être le même
besoin en termes de d'efficacité
vaccinale pour protéger les enfants et
on va s'interroger sur l'efficacité
après à long terme d'un point de vue
épidémiologique au global du pays
protections collectives et en préparant
cette émission toujours jeu réduit le
nombre de doses nécessaires à la
vaccination des enfants elle ressemble
pas tout à fait à ce qu'on fait nous je
voyais deux injections espacées de trois
semaines le laps de temps entre des
injections est beaucoup plus court oui
et non c'est à dire que
pour les adultes c'est quelque chose qui
a bougé pendant la première vague
sylvain pendant la deuxième bac si on se
souvient bien quand on commence à la
vaccination au début l'espacement est
entre quatre et six semaines oui le
royaume uni lui a fait choix d'écarter à
12 semaines donc ccc pour le coup c'est
assez souple ce qui est important c'est
qu'il y ait un temps minimum pendant
lesquelles
notre système immunitaire s'est fait aux
vaccins commença à
décroître en termes de concentrations
d'anticorps et de leurs boostés par
cette seconde dose donc c'est trois
semaines c'est ce que les études de deux
troisièmes du troisième round de
validation des vaccins ont montré la
plus grande efficacité le moment c'est
plus optimum et mais encore une fois
c'est quelque chose d'assez souple sur
ça au royaume uni on a pu espacer
jusqu'à 12 semaines quand on était en
pleine vague épidémique pour vacciner
plus de monde possible que c'est aussi
ça l'enjeu va poser la vaccination des
enfants il faut avoir lu prendre en
compte le contexte international et et
en ayant pandémie est donc en vaccinant
des enfants ici même si ce n'est pas
forcément les mêmes doses on peut
s'interroger sur la priorité de la cité
des enfants qui sont pas à risque alors
qu'il ya un certain nombre de pays qui
n'ont pas encore vaccinés suffisamment
de population et dans lequel le virus
circule est plus un virus circule plus
le risque de voir apparaître un nouveau
variant d'échappement donc il resterait
au au vaccin est important donc c'est
aussi ces questions là qu'il faut
prendre un coup
si des internautes nous écoutent et ont
des enfants concernés par cette tranche
d'âge des enfants à risque des enfants
fragiles ou qu'ils côtoient des
personnes en situation de fragilité
verts qui doivent-ils se tourner pour
aller se faire vacciner est-ce qu'il ya
déjà des des structures qui sont prévus
pour la baptisation des enfants qui ne
sont pas les mêmes que celles qui sont
prévues pour les adultes à partir du
moment où c'est une vaccination des
enfants à risque font un certificat
médical que cette fois de voir son
médecin traitant tous les temps et après
les structures pour le moment
c'est dans les centres de vaccination
qui sont ouverts il me semble pas que
les pharmacies puisse le faire parce que
les pharmaciens c'est surtout moderna et
astrazeneca mais le chemin comme on est
sur un schéma de
qui spécifiques à certains certains
enfants s'est passé par son médecin
traitant son médecin de famille qui est
hui rae qui fournira la
halle ordonnances nécessaires alors
c'est vrai que on peut s'interroger sur
qui sera habilité à vacciner les enfants
on imagine mal les parents à accepter
que ce soit l'usiné ou pharmacien qui
va-t-il leurs enfants et en même temps
vous parlez de médecins généralistes
mais on sait qu'ils sont totalement
débordés avec les
les maladies saisonnières les
bronchiolites etc on fait comment dans
cette période d'infection pour arriver à
trouver quelqu'un qui vaccinent un
enfant pour le moment qu'on commande et
sur les sur les formes sur des enfants
publics spécifiques
je pense pas qu'il y aura de
l'embouteillage et la question va se
poser la question se posera si jamais on
doit ouvrir à tous les enfants et alors
là il ya un certain nombre de l'outil un
la vaccination dans les écoles qui
pourrait être mis en place avec un mot
signé par les parents pour autoriser ou
non l'enfant est de vacciner des plages
horaires spécifiques dans les
dents les dans les centres de
vaccination dont il y aura une
organisation et honnêtement vacciner les
enfants c'est quelque chose qu'on sait
faire qui se fait tous les ans il ya des
rappels
obligatoire l'âge de 6 ans à l'âge de 12
13 ans donc c'est des choses qu'on sait
faire et qu'on pourra mettre en place
mais ceci dit et vous parliez à
l'instant des virus de l'hiver et je
rebondis tue parce que c'est aussi un
élément qui doit doit rentrer en
considération c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
vague dit lié aux locaux vides les
importantes mais elle est beaucoup moins
haute que que les vagues précédentes
mais la vraie différence c'est que le
pays n'est pas confiné il n'y a pas de
restriction on n'est pas sous couvre feu
donc les autres virus circule largement
et on a un niveau de saturation dans le
le monde du soin et particulièrement à
l'hôpital crée très important et c'est
un élément supplémentaire on aura par
l'état l'homme et qui peut peser dans la
balance pour faire vacciner les enfants
parce que ça ça soulagera en partie et
que quand on voit un enfant arrivé avec
une un syndrome respiratoire et qu'on
sait qu'il a été vaccinée pour le covin
on va éliminer au moins c'est cette
hypothèse et on ira vers vers d'autres
qui peuvent être à bloc brocoli qui est
qui et qui circule très activement en ce
moment par exemple alors pour ceux qui
nous suivent en direct en ce moment sur
figaro live et sur notre chaîne youtube
merci d'abord de nous suivre et puis
merci pour vos commentaires alors vous
êtes très nombreux à émettre vraiment
des des doutes et voir des attaques pour
certains concernant la vaccination des
enfants
des suspicions sur la dangerosité du
vaccin sur la manipulation dont feraient
preuve les labos pharmaceutiques alors
je ne peux pas lire tous vos
commentaires mais vous êtes plutôt à
charge contre et des commentaires plutôt
à charge contre la vaccination est
contre les propos que tiennent que tient
vincent bourg de navan notre journaliste
science du figaro qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire vincent bordenave à ses internautes
qui sont sceptiques pour le moins qu'est
ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui des
données de sécurité concernant le vaccin
files heures sur les enfants est ce que
le sérum est sûre est ce qu'aujourd'hui
on peut considérer que voilà les risques
sont limités à very samson sont limités
voire quasi nulle il faut dire ce qui
est on
il ya des pays qui ont commencé c'est ce
que je disais il ya des pays qui ont
commencé à vacciner les enfants les
états unis israël alors ils s'attendent
de pédiatres préfère attendre encore un
peu pour vérifier mais c'est plutôt pour
se rendre compte de l'impact
épidémiologique c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure sur les les limites qu'on
peut avoir sur la le rôle du vaccin pour
limiter la circulation
du virus mais d'un point de vue sécurité
tous les études qui ont été menées ont
été menées de manière transparente et
montrent qu'il n'y a pas de n'y a pas
d'effets secondaires graves pour les
enfants pas plus qu'on a pour pour les
adultes en plus la dose est adapté donc
c'est toujours normal 20 c'est un
nouveau vaccin c'est une nouveau virus
donc c'est normal d'avoir des doutes
d'avoir des réticences de se poser des
questions ça c'est quelque chose de tout
à fait légitime et tout se fait dans
cette pandémie tout se fait quand même
au fur et à mesure on apprend en même
temps que quand on fait les choses là on
a quand même une chance en france et que
on va se poser la question de la
vaccination des enfants alors que
d'autres pays l'ont fait avant nous et
or ont fait des choix avant nous et on
va pouvoir regarder quel sera l'impact à
la fois en termes de sécurité même si ça
s'est fait dans le cadre des essais
cliniques et on a démontré qu'ils
avaient pas deux qui avait pas de danger
et a pris en termes d'impact épidémie au
salon pourra regarder par rapport à ce
qui est fait aux états unis et encore
une fois je répète aux états unis cet
été on a été très inquiet abandonné par
la vague de forme la vague du coc u19 et
de formes graves g chez les enfants on
s'est posé la question est-ce qu'elle va
arriver en france à la rentrée on a vu
que c'était pas le cas et un certain
nombre d'hypothèses et notamment ce que
j'ai sur le le taux d'obésité infantile
qui peuvent l'expliquer et donc la
question se pose de manière légitime et
les chaque pays est différent et je
pense qu aux etats-unis là où les enjeux
sont différents qu'en france c'est pour
ça que l'on répond d'une manière précoce
il ya beaucoup d'internautes évidemment
sur le sujet qui s'interroge je vais
pourquoi n'obligeons pas plutôt les
adultes qui ne sont pas encore vaccinés
à se faire vacciner plutôt que d'aller
imposer un vaccin aux enfants là c'est
une question légitime après on peut
répondre en disant est ce que la bêtise
vaccination n'est pas un parti un peu
obligatoire en france avec le pass alité
en tout cas c'était l'idée et puis ici
on rend la vaccination obligatoire
qu'est ce que ça implique
à partir de mardi qu'elle est
obligatoire on arrive à contrôler la
vaccination pour les plus jeunes par
l'école par les crèches par les lieux de
collectivités pour un adulte ça part et
ça paraît quand même beaucoup plus
compliqué donc le choix qui a été fait
qui est un choix politique encore une
fois il m'appartient pas de commenter
c'est de mettre en pace se place se
passe à lithaire qui rend une
vaccination obligatoire de fait parce
que pour pouvoir vous le savez très bien
les restaurants cinémas etc pourra
sortir et vivre un peu normalement on
est obligé d'être d'être vacciné et
comment aller plus loin et comment
passer l'étape suffisante moi j'ai pas
de jeu pas de solution il ya des pays
qui qui font des choix un peu drastique
qui est de faire payer en 3 qui soulève
l'idée de faire payer les personnes amis
en réanimation non vaccinés
c'est quelque chose extrêmes tels moi je
serais plutôt en profond désaccord
mais c'est des solutions qui sont
apportées objectivement je pense que la
situation est suffisamment compliquée
dans le pays cette question est
suffisamment entendu il faut continuer à
aller vers le maximum de pédagogue de
pédagogie possible et que c'est assez
facile de dire il faut rendre
obligatoire la vaccination mais qu'est
ce que ça implique derrière et là on
rentre dans les considérations
politiques sont beaucoup plus dur et on
va se heurter à des murs sur lesquels on
risque de fracture et la société qui est
déjà acquis des gens en pas très bon
état après deux ans de points de vie
la vaccination des enfants vous en
parliez au début de cet entretien est ce
qu'elle peut elle peut freiner la
circulation du virus ou pas bah c'est
tout le tout l'enjeu un a priori et d'un
point de vue sur le papier d'un point de
vue purement épidémie au oui oui même si
les vaccins sont pas efficaces à 100 %
contre les transmissions même si cette
efficacité n'est que de 50 % et même si
elle serait que de 40% ça a un impact
aujourd'hui au vu du taux d'incidence
sur une classe de 25 élèves il ya une
contamination tous les cinq jours donc
si on ferme les écoles romandes rrr cas
si
on laisse circuler le virus a fait que
nous virus circule comme il est c'est un
impact dramatique à la fois pour les
enfants et pour les adultes donc oui oui
ça peut avoir un impact ça peut freiner
la cinquième vague mais est-ce qu'on va
avoir besoin de ça pour finir 5e bac ça
on aura la réponse pendant les fêtes
tout simplement donc la question se
posera différemment à ce moment là est
tout l'enjeu en fait il est dans les
prochaines semaines toutes les
interrogations qu'on a sur le variant au
micron et c c'est un peu là la clé de la
clé des semaines et des mois à venir et
elle a créé de cette suite de cette
pandémie est ce qu'on est vraiment
arrivé à la fin où est ce qu'on va
reconnaître sternhell recommencement
cette journée la marmotte dont on parle
entre nous ça on le saura
malheureusement c'est une question de
jours pour avoir une idée un peu plus
précise de l'impact de ce variant il
arrive au royaume uni devraient
majoritaire par exemple être hégémonique
en écosse en termes de contamination
d'ici la fin de la semaine et on verra
quel est l'impact de ce variant sur les
courbes épidémique tout simplement si le
nombre de cas graves continuent à
diminuer comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
grâce à la vaccination et troisième dose
si la mortalité a continué à diminuer ou
bien si au contraire si au contraire il
ya un regain au rebond et quelle est la
force de ce rebond est là on se posera
de différentes questions et on sera
obligé d'agir c'est évident est ce que
pour considérer que à moyen terme ou à
plus long terme le vario au micron va
devenir majoritaire en france et en
europe comme c'est le cas pour le
variant delta au mali et honnêtement
linverse très étonnant au vu des
trajectoires actuelle je l'utilisé
notamment au royaume-uni au danemark qui
sont deux pays qui séquence très bien
c'est à dire qu'ils vont non seulement
vérifier si on est malade ou pas mais
qui vont aussi vérifier qu'elle est le
variant en analysant la composition
génétique du virus on voit que la
dynamique elle est favorable à ce
variant mais ce qu'on ne sait pas c'est
quel va être l'impact de ce variant sur
ce qu lisez sur sur l'épidémie on a des
données
sud africaine mais qui sont très
partiales et surtout très précoce a fait
à peine une quinzaine de jours que que
le variant et là on a vu que le nombre
de cas a augmenté très vite une manière
inédite jusqu'à maintenant en afrique du
sud notamment dans la région de l'urban
quinze jours après la courbe de la
mortalité est resté rester plate c'est
plutôt une bonne chose mais ça veut pas
dire qu'il ya trois solutions en fait ça
veut pas dire que ce virus est avérée
sans danger ça ne soit dire que ça n'a
pas encore augmenté ça va augmenter
c'est possible plus le temps passe et
plus cette hypothèse s'éloigne mais ça
ça reste encore possible et je pense
qu'il faut attendre au moins une semaine
encore pour la nature deuxième hypothèse
ça pourrait vouloir dire que le variant
et est moins nocif que les autres
honnêtement il n'y a aucun argument
biologique épidémie au scientifique pour
pouvoir pour argumenter ça mais c'est
une possibilité on peut pas on ne peut
pas l'écarter ce serait un coup de
chance qu'un mec sanguinaire mais c'est
une possibilité et la troisième
hypothèse c'est que l'afrique du sud est
un pays plutôt jeunes où le virus a très
largement circulé pendant les première
vague de l'épidémie et donc où on peut
considérer que la population a déjà un
système immunitaire la fameuse immunité
collective ouais c'est pas tant
collectifs qu'individuels là pour le
coup parce qu'on voit que les cas
augmentent mais qu'un individu helmand
les gens sont son protégé ne sont pas
naïfs face à ce variant donc comme il
est nouveau il va un peu déjoué donc ce
qui va faire que ils vont tomber malade
et ils vont être détectées comme étant
un malade mais comme ils le connaissent
leurs anticorps l'or l'or organisme va
les protéger contre les formes graves et
ça c'est la troisième hypothèse est
toute la question c'est est ce que c'est
cette hypothèse qui tient la corde et
est ce que le vaccin aura le même
pouvoir que cette immunité naturelle
parce qu'on afrique du sud il ya
seulement 25% des gens qui sont
actionnés mais une grande partie des
gens qui ont qui ont été touchés par le
virus et c'est un peu cynique de dire ça
mais on va voir ce qui va se passer dans
les prochains jours au royaume uni et je
disais c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
observer avec une attention très
particulière parce que le variant s'y
propage pour le moment les cours
britannique descendent vers le bas en
termes de formes graves et natalité
c'est une inversion des courbes et et
que les courbes suivent les
contaminations dans ces cas là il va
falloir qu'on doit prendre des mesures
supplémentaires en france et si c'est
pas le cas on
on pourra considérer que les vaccins ont
fait font leur travail et donc continuer
le travail sur la troisième dose etc on
se posera la question de la vaccination
des enfants bien entendu
mais avec ses réticences sur ce nouveau
variant du gène vaccin va perdre de
l'efficacité donc donc toutes ces
questions tout paraît travers sur la
circulation du virus est l'utilité de
plus vous parliez des choix politiques
en matière de vaccination des enfants un
certain nombre d'internautes aussi
s'interroge sur la la le pass sanitaire
qui serait à terme imposer aux 5 11 ans
est-ce que ça va être le cas est ce qu
on sait que c est ce qu on sait si c'est
dans les tuyaux et que ça c'est un
joueur pourrait encore une fois si je
disais à new york cc c'est le cas depuis
depuis il semble aujourd'hui dans les
prochains jours est-ce que ça va être le
cas en france je pense que je ne peux
pas répondre à cette question et même
olivier v en même emmanuel macron pas la
réponse parce qu'on ne sait pas ce que
va donner ce que va donner la vague au
micro ce que je disais à l'instant si
l'état actuel la vaccination du pays
c'est à dire 50 millions de personnes
vaccinées
et 20 millions on espère au moment des
fêtes qui auront alors trois doses
permet de contrôler le nouveau variant
n'y aura pas besoin d'aller plus loin
mais si c'est pas le cas il y aura
besoin de mesures supplémentaires donc
est-ce que ça être inciter toujours plus
à la troisième dose est ce que ça va
suffire j'en sais rien est-ce que ça va
être mettre ces barrières
supplémentaires au niveau des enfants
j'en sais rien ce qui est vrai c'est
qu'on peut pas nier c'est que les
enfants jouent un rôle dans la
circulation du virus que le plus gros
danger pour eux ces deux fermetures
d'écoles s'il ya une vague au micro on
risque je pense pas qu'on risque de
confinement mais bon je ne peux pas
faire battre au savant c'est
effectivement un seul prophète dont les
augures la tuer on sait tous
suffisamment planté
à certains moments de la pandémie pour
pouvoir dire quelque chose mais en tout
cas on risque des fermetures d'écoles ça
c'est évident et donc toute la question
va être de faire peser ce cette balance
bénéfices risques est ce que si en
vaccinant les enfants on limite les
fermetures d'écoles la question pourrait
se poser et tout dépendra des mikron est
donc la question se posera vraiment
janvier je pense je vais vous dire un
dernier commentaire qui synthétise un
peu les commentaires que je vois passer
en nombre sur les tchats du figaro sur
figaro live est sûre et sur youtube qui
comme je vous le disais sont plutôt à
charge contre la vaccination des enfants
aladdin sane n'écrivait sous un papier
du figaro il ya quelques jours je vais
faire vacciner mes enfants pour un virus
qui ne les concerne pas point
d'interrogation pour soi-disant
préserver des grabataires et des
vieillards incapable de prendre soin
d'eux-mêmes tout seul même pas en rêve
les enfants ne sont pas les cobayes de
l'industrie pharmaceutique américaine il
ya plusieurs choses dans ce commentaire
mot cobayes je pense qu'il est quand
même profondément impropre parce que
c'est quand on essaye un vaccin
entraînement met en place un système de
suivi
l'allaitait sont passés donc il n'y a
pas du tout de côté cobayes il ya une
interrogation ce que je disais sur
l'intérêt épidémie au vu de l'efficacité
du vaccin sur les transmissions donc
c'est pas une question de cobayes c'est
vrai on va poser le pour le compte de
l'utilité des choix seront faits à ce
moment là et on pourrait en débattre
pour le moment le on en est pas encore
là mais je le disais c'est que au
micro-ondes va quand même rabat un
certain nombre de cartes et il ya
deuxième partie de de l'intervention je
vais pas vacciner mais mes enfants pour
les gravats terre etc
je comprends qu'on s'interroge la
vaccination des enfants alors moi vous
allez dire je suis moi j'ai des enfants
qui ont 2 ans et 1 mois donc à titre
personnel je suis pas concerné mais s'il
avait entre 5 et 11 ans je me poserai
bien entendu la question
pendant toute la pandémie dans le
service aux sciences du figaro on se
posait des questions sur est ce que il
faut durcir il faut pas durcir on
n'était pas d'accord et c'est il ya
quand même un élément qui m'ont
abandonné m'a convaincu qu'un certain
nombre de choix qui ont été faits à
l'est aller dans le bon sens c'est que
on note
la grandeur d'une civilisation et d'une
démocratie à sa capacité à pratiquer
protéger les plus fragiles et que
laisser circuler virus largement c'est
un impact dramatique pour un certain
d'une part de la population donc c'est
peut-être des personnes âgées mais c'est
les personnes les plus fragiles et donc
il faut collectivement se donner les
outils pour les protéger donc bien
entendu à protéger les plus fragiles ça
se fait de manière mesurée en ayant
conscience des impacts pour tout un
chacun
mais si on doit vacciner des enfants
pour protéger les plus vieux moi je
pense que la société en sortira grandie
bien entendu il faudra le faire si c'est
utile et seulement si c'est utile et on
ne peut pas rejeter rejeté rejeté cet
élément là on peut pas accepter
justement que que des gens meurent alors
qu'on a des solutions pour pour les
aider même au delà de gens qui meurent
de gens souffrent la réanimation c'est
pas quelque chose agréable et même il
n'ya pas que les plus fragiles qui sont
concernées à des gens en bonne santé qui
qu'ils ont à partir on a les outils pour
éviter ça il faut pouvoir les utiliser
mais bien entendu il faut le faire de
manière intelligente et en prenant en
compte l'ensemble des bénéfices et des
risques pour le moins pour les enfants
toutes les questions n'ont pas encore
été non pas été en clair si y'a quand
même un certain nombre de scientifiques
qui explique que la balance bénéfice
risque défavorable parce que bien
entendu à titre individuel il n'y a pas
beaucoup de bénéfices à part ce que je
disais sur les écoles etc et puis même
vivre de manière générale dans une
société pandémique mais en termes de
risques des risques sont nulles et ça
c'est important de le dire c'est que
toutes les études le montrent des
risques sont nulles pour les enfants en
termes de vaccination et que si un
enfant on attrape le coc vide il a très
peu de chances d'attraper de faire une
forme grave mais il ya quand même des
possibilités de complications qu'on
appelle les pimms les vaccins les
réduisent considérablement donc même sur
ce risque très faible la balance
bénéfices risques est favorable au
vaccin donc ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut même pas lui
merci beaucoup de vincent bordenave pour
vos éclairages et votre témoignage merci
à tous de nous avoir suivis en direct on
espère avoir été complet sur ce sujet de
la vaccination des enfants dont je
rappelle que ce sont les plus fragiles
qui sont invitées à se faire vacciner à
partir de ce mercredi 15 décembre et
peut-être que la vaccination s'ouvrira
aux enfants dans leur ensemble dans la
tranche 5 à 11 ans dans les jours les
semaines qui arrivent à voir merci
encore de nous avoir suivis merci pour
vos commentaires pas toujours très
agréable mais ça fait partie du jeu a
très vite sur figaro lève